et voilà c'était
Ukraine des photographes dans la guerre
un film essentiel écrit par Frédéric de
caussat et réalisé par Julien Boluen
bonjour à tous les deux merci d'avoir
accepté l'invitation de Z la Zone
d'Éducation documentaire alors vous
connaissez le principe ce sont les
élèves du collège Georges Clémenceau ici
à Paris qui vont vous poser plein de
questions bonjour les élèves
mais juste avant de vous laisser
échanger avec nos deux invités
j'aimerais vous poser quelques questions
j'aimerais que vous me disiez ce que
vous avez pensé de ce documentaire quand
vous entendez le mot guerre à quoi vous
pensez une
destructions bombardements Elyès le
combat et quand je vous dis photographe
vous pensez à quoi
journaliste journaliste réalité
vous saviez que ça existait des
photographes de guerre non il y en a
d'autres qui ont découvert le métier de
photographe de guerre
qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit sur ce
métier c'était dangereux que c'était
dangereux ça doit être dur de prendre
des photos comme ça
on va passer à vos questions et on va
commencer avec Mélina une question pour
Monsieur beaulieuen est-ce que vous
aviez une idée de ce que vous vouliez
filmer et raconter avant de partir en
reportage ou est-ce que cela se
construit quand vous étiez en Ukraine
alors moi c'était ma première guerre
donc en fait j'étais un peu comme vous
j'avais vu la guerre soit dans les films
soit dans les magazines ou à l'école et
donc je ne savais pas du tout où
j'allais et donc moi j'ai suivi donc un
grand photographe de guerre Eric Bouvet
qui a plus de 30 ans de reportage de
guerre à son actif et c'est un peu je
l'ai un peu suivi en fait moi c'est lui
qui m'a appris un peu les codes comment
faire attention j'étais comme vous en
fait donc j'ai découvert la guerre avec
lui à travers son regard mais c'est vrai
que la particularité d'un terrain comme
ça c'est que il était complètement
dépendant de ce qui se passait jour
après jour donc même si on imagine un
peu on essaye d'imaginer ce qui va se
passer quelle séquence serait bien de
ramener on est dépendant du terrain
alors justement est-ce que vous pourriez
nous rappeler simplement quels étaient
vos rôles à tous les deux
parties sur le terrain parce qu'il est
il est cadreur et réalisateur et moi je
me suis plus occupé du montage du film
et d'interviewer les photographes qui
étaient à Paris mamie Célia on t'écoute
qui choisit le texte raconté par la voix
off alors là c'est moi qui l'ai écrit
je l'ai fait lire à Julien qu'il a
amendé donc c'est un commentaire qui
écrit qui est dicté par les thématiques
et donner au spectateur à vous qui
regardez le film les informations utiles
pour que vous compreniez ce qui se passe
parce qu'il y a des fois où tout ne se
passe pas dans l'image et on est obligé
décrypter un tout petit peu Chems j'ai
une question pour Julien Bauduin
quel titre
dans ce documentaire
moi j'ai rien voulu créer comme ambiance
j'ai juste voulu retranscrire la vérité
on a juste à tourner à appuyer sur REC
en fait pour pour enregistrer une
situation qui est terrible quoi donc
c'est des gens qui meurent c'est des
gens qui fuient leur pays des femmes et
des enfants
en fait on subit quoi quelque part même
nous il fait le modeste parce que il a
quand même un
œil une attirance pour des choses qui
peuvent être hors de la guerre je sais
pas si vous vous rappelez après le
générique on tombe sur un vieux monsieur
qui tombe qui joue du violon et qui joue
du bac quand Julien l'a entendu il l'a
vu il s'est dit c'est formidable donc il
l'a tourné et effectivement dans le film
ce mélange de musique de Bach avec ce
violon désaccordé où il y a plus que
trois cordes et le chat ukrainien qui
passe au loin c'est prenant ça voilà et
donc
je crois qu'on ne fait pas que subir
c'est-à-dire que il a l'oeil et les
oreilles aux aguets en permanence pour
justement peut-être trouver des choses
un tout petit peu décalé mais qui
veulent dire beaucoup de choses et qui
crée justement une ambiance complète un
petit peu ce que tu ce que tu as voulu
dire mais le choix de cette musique
plutôt classique voilà tout au long de
du film pourquoi
mais parce qu'on est on est sur des
sentiments qui sont qui sont quand même
forts et des images qui sont
qui peuvent être dures et donc on a
voulu une musique qui ne soit pas trop
prenantes qui soit
plus en ambiance et plus pour
accompagner ce sentiment de développe
les photos et les images de Julien alors
justement ces photographes qu'on suit là
pendant tout le film vous les trouvez
comment prudent ou pas du tout
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont pas peur du
danger Mélina j'ai envie de dire pas
prudent avec du sang-froid
pourquoi parce qu'ils se mettent en
danger constamment mais ils savent ils
savent se protéger quand même
alors c'est indéniable il y a un peu le
côté voilà adrénaline etc mais on est
quand même là-bas aussi pour défendre
quelque chose là on défend quand même
une invasion enfin on défend un pays qui
est en train de se faire envahir c'est
j'ai ressenti un besoin en fait de de
dénoncer des choses de documenter des
choses
vous parle aussi ce que dit Chloé
complètement parce qu'en fait on est
dans des situations extraordinaires
ce qui nous habite c'est vraiment
raconter l'histoire de ces gens-là donc
effectivement on risque notre vie
mais on le fait vraiment pour eux c'est
une passion en fait là les gens te
donnent tout pour que tu réussisses pour
que tu puisses montrer donc à vous
quelle est leur quotidien en fait moi je
voulais pas partir en fait du crâne
parce que je laissais plein de gens
derrière moi qui vivaient encore la
guerre et en fait j'ai envie de raconter
toutes ces histoires juste peut-être
pour ajouter sur le risque il n'y a pas
d'inconscience regardez Eric ça fait 40
ans à peu près qui couvre tous les
conflits de la terre il s'est retrouvé
dans des situations absolument
incroyables inimaginable indescriptible
il est toujours là il est toujours là
parce que
il sait jusqu'où aller il va pas prendre
de risque inconsidéré il a une telle
expérience du terrain que il sait
qu'elle pas en trop il ne faut pas faire
et ce sont des gens qui prennent
beaucoup énormément de précautions et
qui ne se font pas happer par la
situation est-ce que pour autant pour
prendre une bonne photo
alors c'est la question qu'on leur pose
dans le film et
[Musique]
et le sentiment à vous moi mon sentiment
c'est que il faut pas forcément être
sous les bons pour prendre une bonne
photo ou alors ce que dit Guillaume
aussi dans le film un cadavre tout seul
ne veut pas dire qu'en chose un cadavre
dans un jardin avec un nain de jardin et
là ça veut dire beaucoup de choses parce
que vous vous nous en tant que
spectateur de cette photographie on peut
se projeter on peut imaginer l'horreur
et tout est dans l'imagination c'est pas
forcément la violence pure à l'image
Julien Bollène
inconscience pour moi parce qu'en fait
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on doit
montrer dans une guerre donc il y a tout
donc effectivement ça peut être plus
soft et puis après on peut vraiment
montrer la vraie guerre des images
vraiment terribles des enfants morts des
enfants déchiquetés mais c'est horrible
mais la guerre c'est ça mais ça on peut
pas vraiment le montrer parce que déjà
personne n'a envie de voir ça mais la
guerre c'est ça après on peut nuancer on
peut faire des images
implicite voilà pour que le message
passe elles sont très importantes on
peut recevoir beaucoup d'émotions les on
les voyants
quand même la guerre c'est quelque chose
de sale c'est ça la réalité des choses
donc est-ce qu'il y a une part
d'inconscience si on a envie de montrer
vraiment la guerre comme elle est oui
quand même quelques moi je fais beaucoup
de reportages à travers le monde qui
sont difficiles mais je risque pas ma
vie comme je l'ai fait en Ukraine quand
vous dormez dans un hôtel et que c'est
bombardé toute la nuit et que vous savez
pas si vous allez vous réveiller le
lendemain parce que les bombes elles
tombent un peu au pif bon bah c'est de
l'inconscience on va pas se mentir c'est
enfin moi c'est mon point de vue Alexis
on t'écoute pourquoi on refait ce choix
de traiter du regard humaniste des
photos reporters notre matière première
la matière première d'un documentaire
généralement c'est l'humain et donc on a
véritablement voulu faire non pas un
film de guerre où on est derrière Julien
serait derrière les tanks en train de
d'observer le moindre obus qui tombe etc
mais simplement des histoires d'hommes
et de femmes dans la guerre
on continue avec Alicia
sur quel sujet souhaitez-vous
particulièrement faire réagir ou
réfléchir le spectateur et comment
allez-vous procéder dans la mise en
scène le point de départ du film ça a
été un ça a été un questionnement par
rapport au photographes et vraiment les
deux questions qu'on s'est posées avec
Julien c'était mais ce que je disais
tout à l'heure
pourquoi vous avez envie d'aller là-bas
d'aller au milieu des bombes au milieu
des snipers marcher sur une mine au
milieu de la souffrance et de la douleur
et qu'est-ce que vous en ramenez et
comment vous vous vivez votre vie
normale à Paris
avec ces images avec ces images dans la
tête donc voilà ça ça a été les deux
questions fondamentales
dans le métro dans une vie quotidienne
voilà pour qu'on se rend compte qu'en
fait ces gens-là voulaient croient vous
les croisez mais ils ont été aux quatre
coins du monde faire toutes les guerres
possible imaginables et en fait
on les croise comme ça mais c'est des
gens qui ont vu des choses incroyables
enfin vraiment très dur quoi c'est quand
même il faut être fort quand même
mentalement pour faire ce genre de
métier enfin parce que sinon on peut
devenir fou il y a ce qu'on ressent en
tant que photographe mais il y a aussi
travaillé entre guillemets pour
l'histoire il y a qui n'est peut-être
pas dit dans le film mais il y a
beaucoup de photos à eux qui ne sont pas
parues mais qui sont gardés dans des
tiroirs dans des musées et ou dans des
bibliothèques et qui feront œuvres
historiques est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut tout montrer
Alexis moi je pense qu'il faut tout
filmer mais il faut tout laisser de
garder la dignité des personnes qu'on
filme moi je pense qu'un juste milieu il
faut savoir respecter les choses
confines mais en même temps parce que le
but du documentaire c'est d'informer les
gens donc savoir respecter la vie privée
et aussi informer je pense que c'est un
juste milieu oui au revoir
la réalité ça choquerait mais ce serait
pas grave je crée mais si ça me
choquerai mais on mange c'est vrai que
ça c'est la réalité vous êtes d'accord
pour moi parce que comme les gens ils
peuvent pas se mettre à la place des
Ukrainiens il faut tout leur montrer
pour
un peu à il se met derrière place moi de
tout ce que j'ai vu des choses très très
bien je critique pas mais mais il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin parce que c'est
pas ce que j'ai vu mon Rohff
après il y a le questionnement qui est
dans le film d'ailleurs la violence en
train de la violence jusqu'où on va
aller un exemple un peu quelqu'un qui
était décédé il y avait des vers qui
sortaient de ses yeux bon on a mais
c'est horrible mais c'est voilà désolé
mais est-ce que je vais faire la photo
pour me rapprocher pour voir les verres
sortir des yeux non
c'est un super exemple
[Rires]
ou pas non
ça ce serait trop pour vous est-ce que
ça aurait un intérêt
d'aller juste non pourquoi
ça va on va juste avoir des mauvaises
images dans la tête on continue avec Tom
quoi dans les deux côtés je pense que
c'est exactement la même chose c'est à
dire qu'en fait il y a beaucoup de
militarus qui ont rien demandé et qui
subissent la plupart je pense subissent
cette gare-là tout autant que les
Ukrainiens pourquoi nous avons montré la
guerre que du côté grenier
suivre du côté russe pour avoir leur
point de vue aussi à eux suivre les
militaires sur place
mais ça ça nous a été refusé on peut pas
cette guerre en Ukraine est aussi une
guerre de communication on le voit bien
avec zenenski qui parle aux Ukrainiens
et aux Européens et au monde entier
presque tous les jours de l'autre côté
Poutine ou son porte-parole voilà c'est
des vérités qui s'affrontent des
contre-vérités qui s'affrontent et ils
ne veulent pas qui est des journalistes
là au milieu en train de dire non non
mais est-ce que vous avez dit c'est
n'importe quoi parce que regardez mon
image ça dit exactement le contraire
j'imagine je fais une des gens des
Ukrainiens qui tuent des Russes
tu vas dire mais ils sont c'est des
barbares enfin ils ont pas le droit de
faire ça ils vissent vers ça pour les
Russes bah ouais ils veulent pas montrer
ça en fait les deux côtés est-ce que
vous croyez qu'il y a des propagande
bah oui mais ça c'est j'ai envie de dire
alors c'est un grand sujet c'est une
grosse question mais de la propagande
oui il y en a toujours il y en a
toujours comment on fait pour pas être
utilisé alors à ce moment-là non mais ça
va même ça va vraiment l'image pure
c'est un photographe à partir du moment
que je te filme comme ça je te fais une
photo comme ça où on compte ça dit pas
la même chose en fait donc tout est
alors je sais pas si c'est propagande
parce que propagande c'est vraiment pour
pour enfoncer un propos mais en fait
tout est rien des neutre en fait dans
une image de la part des des états
majors enfin moi je pense que ce n'est
que de la propagande il n'y a que ça
comment ne pas être utilisé c'est
justement le travail fondamental dans
Photos reporter photo journaliste ils
ont une part de journalistes et comme le
dit Eric dans le film
ils ne vont pas sortir une info sans
relavoir vérifier trois fois par trois
sources différentes ça c'est extrêmement
important à l'heure des réseaux sociaux
vous qui êtes submergé dans un
tourbillon d'images un flot continue etc
il faut avant de croire quelque chose
avant de penser que c'est une
information il faut recouper et avoir
différentes sources
indépendantes et qui donne la même info
et là vous pouvez être sûr à peu près ou
alors c'est vraiment ils sont ils sont
très forts en face mais que l'info est
véritable est-ce que vous comprenez ça
le fait de vérifier l'information que ce
soit les photos reporters ou même les
documentaristes qui sont là en face de
vous quand ils récupèrent les images
qu'elles viennent de sur place ou
d'ailleurs il faut vérifier les
informations c'était tout le propos
comment vous la suivez vous cette guerre
Elias sur Twitter
et donc du coup tout ce que vous
regardez c'est forcément en vrai
faut pas se leurrer vous avez peut-être
tous entendu parler des usines à trolls
chinoises russes etc qui essayent
d'influencer notre vision
de fait internationaux ou même de faits
nationaux la désinformation et la
propagande elle est là tous les jours un
smart on t'écoute
est-ce que vous ressentez de l'empathie
envers le risque du fixer ou de la
fixeuse comment avez-vous rencontré et
est-ce qu'on peut lui faire confiance
c'est super question parce qu'on en
parle très peu des fixeurs et des
fixeuses
univers stock
le métier de fixeur sur place avant la
guerre n'avait peut-être 15 fixeurs dans
le pays parce que des documentaires en
Ukraine il n'y avait pas tous les jours
là il y a 2000 journalistes qui arrivent
qui 2000 journalistes qui veulent 2000
fixer et donc en fait il y a des gens
qui se sont qui ont appris le métier
quand même c'est une mère de famille
incroyablement courageux enfin
incroyable
elle le faisait pour son pays en fait
tout simplement pour elle elle n'était
pas en première ligne mais c'était un
moyen combattre les Russes et donner sa
part en fait à son pays donc c'est c'est
très beau donc nous on a vu ça puis on
l'a un peu formé parce qu'on a un peu
plus l'habitude et comme on fait
confiance alors c'est un peu au petit
bonheur
faut avoir beaucoup de contact donc
c'est quand même pas mal de monde aussi
dans l'armée tout ça donc elle nous a
ouvert des portes donc c'est aussi pour
ça qu'on l'a pris
c'est là le rôle essentiel on en parle
jamais assez de ces gens-là fixeur et
fixeuse que ce soit l'Ukraine je ne sais
pas le Congo Botswana ou la Bolivie
tarif tu connais pas ta culture la
culture les problèmes administratifs du
pays comment tu peux contacter etc on
peut faire nos films ou les photographes
peuvent faire leur photo généralement
grâce à eux tu peux pas arriver comme ça
you play dans un pays et dire je vais me
débrouiller tout seul c'est pas possible
donc ce sont des gens absolument
essentiels on en parle jamais assez de
ces gens-là
est-ce que vous enfin quel a été votre
l'image qui va plus marqué l'image donc
on va revenir sur sur la gare en fait il
y a pas de mort il y a finalement c'est
une image mais ça c'est très fort en
émotion enfin ça me restera cette photo
à la gare de Kiev de la main du papa sur
la sur la vitre du train avec la la
petite main de son fils de l'autre côté
voilà ça c'est des images qui sont
d'autres se sont dit qu'il y avait
d'autres images qui les avaient qui les
auraient peut-être plus touchés ou
vraiment la guerre ça a été quelque
chose de plus dur à regarder pour vous
oui Alexis
monsieur qui est en train de mourir tout
seul ah oui qu'est-ce qui t'a touché
particulièrement dans cette séquence là
il y a personne pour l'accompagnement
ELISA
est-ce que il y a des photos que vous
avez choisi de ne pas montrer et si oui
pourquoi alors ce que dit Chloé ce que
disent tous les photographes dans le
film un moment c'est à dire que ils
prennent des photos presque
chirurgicales de temps en temps mais
mais vraiment extrêmement dur c'est
c'est
la médecine légale quasiment mais celle
là elles sont pas parues elles sont
apparaissent nulle part elles sont
gardées et si un jour on sait jamais il
y a des procès pour crime de guerre et
ben ressentir ressortiront ces photos en
tant que preuve
comment les photos reporters se
démarquent-ils les uns des autres
alors la photo en fait malheureusement
la photo c'est très compliqué d'en vivre
est-ce qu'il y a une concurrence bah oui
indirectement il y a quand même une
concurrence parce qu'en fait il y a très
peu de magazines qui achètent pour les
photographes donc il y a beaucoup de
photos rares pour finalement très peu de
demandes de magasins chacun essaye de se
démarquer de l'autre en racontant des
histoires et en faisant des photos qui
sont propres à eux en fait d'ailleurs
c'est dans le documentaire il y a quatre
styles de photos ils ont leur studies
différents ils ont voilà
après sur des terrains aussi compliqués
que des terrains de guerre il y a plutôt
une solidarité mais oui forcément comme
le disait Julien c'est une histoire
d'entonnoir il y a beaucoup de gens pour
peu de médias peu de place dans les
médias donc c'est entre guillemets au
meilleur ou à celui qui a un regard un
peu décalé ou qui apporte plus
d'informations ou qui était là où les
autres ne sont pas ou qui a des contacts
ou etc et C Asma on continue avec toi
les deux mais tout dépend où je suis
c'est à dire que
je sais pas je suis sur un champ de
bataille il y a des gens qui sont
décédés je vais pas chercher à faire du
beau je vais chercher juste à faire la
photo qui servira de témoignages
ensuite je vais par exemple c'est une
maman qui revoit son fils qui rentre de
guerre oui je vais essayer de la photo
soit belle qui est de l'émotion tout
dépend vraiment de sujet de la photo
après on peut faire du beau aussi
également dans des dans des situations
atroces mais ça c'est tout tout dépend
de photographe si tu fais quelque chose
de très léché très esthétique et qui est
au milieu de cette esthétisme il y a
quelque chose d'horrible
je pense que c'est c'est d'autant plus
marquant et c'est d'autant plus fort
l'horreur te saute à la figure parce que
tout autour est beau
qu'est-ce que tu en penses toi
une photo de guerre elle peut être belle
pour moi une photo de guerre faut
qu'elle soit bien prise pour se dire
quoi ça veut dire faut que quand on
regarde la photo
je sais pas comment je sais pas comment
on peut dire ça mais l'information oui
voilà mais d'accord c'est pas la même
chose que la photo est belle est-ce que
si la photo est belle tu penses qu'elle
est encore plus forte ou pas forcément
oui pour moi la photo de dire ça veut
pas être beau parce que la guerre c'est
déjà c'est pas beau
comment dire si la prend pour le côté
artistique toi tu es d'accord avec ça tu
penses qu'on peut faire une photo
artistique quand on est sur un terrain
de guerre
mais ça va être dur
dans quel sens quand tu as regardé
l'image tu vas voir que
c'est triste quoi
et donc c'est encore plus triste si
c'est beau pas forcément
Elissa
est-ce que vous considérez une photo de
guerre comme
comme une œuvre d'art
tout dépend la photo encore une fois
c'est toujours le qu'est-ce qu'on
photographie après moi personnellement
je vois quelqu'un qui est décédé par
terre je me permettrai pas mais c'est
mon point de vue de faire une photo
esthétique et essayer de chercher à
faire du beau dans l'horreur mais après
c'est vraiment un point de vue personnel
c'est le beau sert le message ou pas je
crois qu'on a pas en fait on réfléchit
pas comme ça enfin quand on voit
quelqu'un qui est décédé un enfant qui
est décédé devant soi
enfin moi ça me vient même pas l'esprit
d'essayer de faire quelque chose
d'esthétique quand vous arrivez à
déclencher sur un moment d'un obus qui
explose ou d'une maison qui explose etc
vous allez avoir forcément ces flammes
ça va être esthétique enfin je crois que
il va y avoir une dimension esthétique
qui peut entre guillemets peut-être que
le terme n'est pas le bon mais peut le
sublimer oui peut peut le rendre encore
plus prégnant le bon exemple je crois
que c'est un peu dans le documentaire
c'est la photo d'Eric Bouvet avec cet
hélicoptère qui s'est écrasé et on voit
la personne donc là il a composé l'image
là c'est un voilà il a voulu
l'esthétiser un peu parce qu'il s'est
placé de telle manière que ça fasse une
photo esthétique et là pour moi ça passe
Sébastian moi c'est pour Frédéric de
caussas
considérez-vous la réalition de films
documentaire comme appartenant à la
création artistique je pense que le
documentaire
c'est
ça regroupe tellement de choses mais
c'est totalement créatif parce que ça ne
s'intéresse qu'à ce qu'on vit tous les
jours
mettre en scène la réalité essayer de la
retranscrire c'est de la filmer au mieux
au plus près de la manière la plus
réaliste
esthétiquement ou pas c'est un vrai
travail de création ça te fait être
curieux ça te fait te poser des
questions sur ce que tu vis tous les
jours et c'est une matière première qui
est absolument formidable et totalement
créative et imaginative oui mais sans
tricher attention pourquoi cette
précision sans tricher parce que on fait
du documentaire donc entre guillemets
parce que le mot est peut-être un peu
fort mais on fait acte de vérité même si
on a notre point de vue on va pas
modifier la réalité c'est pas notre but
au contraire on est là pour et vous
informer et vous donner de quoi
réfléchir si c'est possible de quoi vous
questionner vous laisser un espace dans
le film et donc c'est pour ça que on ne
triche pas il m'arrive souvent plusieurs
mois après de retomber sur des
reportages rééditeurs reportage et me
dire sais pas où j'ai vu ça
me semble complètement absurde
complètement irréaliste en fait donc
j'ai vraiment sur le moment une vraie
concentration une mise à distance je
suis pas du genre m'effondrer le soir du
tout ce qui veut pas dire que là en
Ukraine je
commence à faire des cauchemars voilà
c'était moche quoi mais c'est peut-être
pour ça que je suis que j'y vais aussi
pour me rendre compte que la vie c'est
pas simplement
s'acheter des nouvelles baskets et puis
essayer de gagner plus de pognon et
avoir une nouvelle bagnole
est-ce que ce documentaire il vous a
aussi
aidé à changer votre regard sur le sur
le monde sur votre vie à vous oui nous
on est heureux on est bien on peut aller
à l'école alors que en Ukraine c'est pas
si loin que ça il y a des enfants ils
vivent dans le froid ils ont pas
forcément tout le temps à manger enfin
voilà
qu'on doit être satisfait avec ce qu'on
a et pas vouloir plus
il y a des gens qui n'ont même pas ce
que nous on a
dire que quand nous on passe une journée
de cours normal bayana il passe une
journée catastrophique avec des
bombardements et une journée difficile
alors que nous souvent on dit que quand
je la passer une journée longue alors
qu'il y en a ils sont vraiment passés
une journée même très longue et même que
Alexandre
quand vous êtes rentré en France
alors j'avais entendu parler des grands
reporters de guerre qui avait le
syndrome post traumatique c'est ça donc
c'est à dire c'est un syndrome en gros
tu es choqué donc tu fais des cauchemars
dès qu'il y a un pétard ou un boom ça te
crée un une peur en fait tu réagis comme
ça moi j'avais fait beaucoup de grosses
portages avant donc je m'étais dit bon
je vais voir ce que ça va faire parce
que j'ai quand même pas mal de morts et
effectivement quand je suis rentré ça
m'était jamais arrivé en fait j'ai fait
pendant deux trois semaines des
cauchemars un de mes collègues qui était
avec moi pendant trois quatre mois un
jeune qui est pourtant très courageux
donc ça n'enlève rien dès qu'il
entendait un pétard mais vraiment
traumatisé à se mettre par terre
donc ouais il y a quelque chose qui
reste j'ai été dans énormément de pays
très pauvres
mais c'est pas la guerre la guerre c'est
vraiment particulier je suis allé je ne
connaissais pas mais oui clairement
est-ce que d'après vous Julien Bollène
il doit y retourner ou pas et après on
lui posera la question
mais vous vous en pensez quoi oui je
pense qu'il va y retourner
des trucs dans le
documentaire vous êtes tous d'accord
avec ça
il se peut que ça peut être plus violent
que ce qu'il ait vu et que du coup ça ça
qu'on dit ça
ça grave le syndrome qui dans lequel il
avait parlé ok
c'est bon moi je dis qu'il doit y
retourner mais aussi qu'il doit pas y
retourner d'une part il doit y retourner
parce que les gens ils oublient pas la
guerre et de notre part parce que c'est
dangereux aussi c'est sa vie qui c'est
votre vie qui est en danger et après ça
reste votre choix personnel alors Julien
beaulieuen vous allez retourner ou pas
y retourner pour revoir les gens que
j'ai rencontré là-bas savoir ce qu'ils
sont devenus et ce que le pays devient
et Julien Bollène
ça nous fera un deuxième documentaire
pour très bien mais non mais de toute
façon je crois que
une des choses classiques c'est que je
crois une fois qu'on a mis le doigt dans
l'engrenage de ces choses là de ces
montées d'adrénaline et de d'avoir
l'impression de de participer ou de
d'être spectateur de l'écriture de
l'histoire je crois qu'on a envie des
retourner merci beaucoup merci merci à
vous deux l'émission et déjà terminé un
grand bravo à vous les élèves vous
pouvez vous applaudir c'était super
vraiment et puis on peut applaudir aussi
vos deux professeurs madame bonnabo et
Madame Jacquot qui nous ont permis de
mettre en place ce programme et nous on
se retrouve très vite avec une nouvelle
classe et un nouveau documentaire parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour questionner
le monde et ces images allez salut salut
les élèves merci encore merci c'était
trop bien bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]